also tonight coming up a bombshell new
development from the durham probe we
also have disturbing new video showing
alleged antifa rioting attacking
republicans in portland by the way
police took forever to get there uh the
biden administration is celebrating a
looming food shortage that would force
america's farmers to quote go green
really that's the next crop
that's the next inflation that's the
next uh hike on gas now we the food
prices aren't high enough
anyway we'll also weigh in on joe's big
weekend in washington d.c by the way my
record is intact
in all the years i've been on radio 35
years 26 and a half years at fox i've
never been to a single white house
correspondents dinner and i did not
break that record and show up this
weekend and i never will i know they
don't like me i don't particularly like
them so let's not play games anyway
uh they did have some fun good at our
expense that's also good and saturday's
white house correspondents dinner we'll
give you an update now we want to
introduce you to a not so bright msdnc
host who's having a really hard time
with coping with twitter's new ownership
now we go to one of their hosts i don't
really know this guy maddie hassan uh
his dangerous neo-nazis are now poised
to take over the country all because
elon musk bought twitter and elon musk
is saying stay on twitter all my critics
feel free to attack me because that's
what free speech is all about they're
that upset take a look
we are living through an unspeakably
dangerous moment the pro-q anon
pro-neo-nazi faction of the republican
party is poised to expand dramatically
come the midterms
we're just two years away from donald
trump very possibly re-seizing executive
power
if that happens we may look back on this
past week as a pivotal moment when a
petulant and not so bright billionaire
casually bought one of the world's most
influential messaging machines
and just handed it to the far right
now today elon musk he responded
tweeting out quote nbc is basically
saying republicans are nazis by the way
elon i don't know if you've ever watched
the show or you're watching tonight um
every single day used to be every two
years every four years now it's pretty
much every day republicans are racist
sexist homophobic xenophobic
islamophobic now transphobic they want
dirty air and water they want grandma
and grandpa only to eat dog and cat food
and then they want some prominent
republican look alike to take granny and
grandpa in a wheelchair and throw him
over a cliff welcome to my world welcome
to the world of conservatism
this is the same organization that
covered up the hunter biden laptop he
goes on and had the harvey weinstein
story early and they killed it and they
built matt lauer he wrote his rape
office woof i think he's talking about
that lock thing that had been reported i
don't know if that was ever verified uh
lovely people he writes anyway i'll add
this is the same network that brings you
joy reid conspiracy theorist of all time
rachel maddow and until recently lion
brian williams you know the guy that saw
dead bodies floating during katrina in
front of his hotel
that wasn't flooded and needless to say
nbc news doesn't exactly value truth
neither does fake news cnn for that
matter both organizations are only
propaganda arms for the dnc they peddle
in lives conspiracy theories always to
advance the socialist agenda hate on
conservative
everything conservative and trump and
all trump supporters and on sunday one
cnn guest called for the federal
government to step in
regulate discourse on twitter before
it's too late take a look
musk doesn't want you know he's upset
with the sec tried to call how dare they
question him you know what i'm saying
this is dangerous we can't think anymore
in this country we don't have people no
i'm serious we don't have people in
congress who can make regulations that
can make it work i think we can look to
the western countries in europe for how
they are trying to limit it but you need
you need controls on this you need
regulation you cannot let these guys
control discourse in this country or we
are headed to hell we are there trump
opened the gate to hell and now they're
chasing us down
now where were these people when donald
trump conservatives banned suspended
canceled shadow banned you know this is
the common team on the left it's called
hypocrisy unlike many of my so-called
competitors
i've never called for any show or any
host or any guest to be canceled or
boycotted or censored i believe in free
speech and if we don't like what they
say i hope you tune them out most
americans already are but according to
them the american people you can't be
trusted only big mother government knows
right from wrong for example while msdnc
and fake news cnn freak out about elon
musk and free speech on twitter all of a
sudden ignored it all this time they're
all but applauding the homeland security
secretary in his announcement or
pronouncement of a creepy new
disinformation governance board or as we
call it on this show the socialist
democrats minister of leftist truth
watch this
here in the u.s there's been an uproar
in recent days about the department of
homeland security setting up what they
call a disinformation governance board
this has been mostly a fox world story
it uh it could come up earlier today on
cnn state of the union but i don't think
people know what it is and what it isn't
and there's just been a lot of of
right-wing uproar without knowing what
it is so
now keep in mind the dhs they were
founded after 9 11 we lost nearly 3 000
of our fellow americans they were
designed to prevent another 911 another
attack on the homeland but under
secretary mayorkas what the department
has now turned their focus inward a
complete dereliction of duty a complete
retreat from a post-9 11 world and
policies to keep every american and this
country safe from terrorists by the way
how many terrorist encounters did they
have at the border 41 we don't even know
how many people might have snuck in that
we don't know about and according to
mayorkist disinformation and climate
change they are the crises of the day
and apparently we have no one to blame
but ourselves in other words the
administration actually believes the
greatest threat to this great country
are we the american people we've got to
look into
domestic terrorism those scary mommies
and daddies at school board meetings
that will be investigated for domestic
terrorism if they dare to raise their
voice against crt or age inappropriate
education and counter to this grave
threat mayorkas announced a new ministry
of truth to be led by a far left lunatic
who ironically
spreads a ton of disinformation all the
time for example in april 2020 uh nina
jankowicz referred to the kova 19 lab
league theory as a baseless rumor spread
by trump supporters false chinese
state-run media frequently cited her
fictitious claims using them in their
own disinformation campaign and
jankowitz also spread misinformation
playing down the hunter biden laptop she
called that a trump campaign product
another disinformation lie she praised
this information dossier author
christopher steele and on twitter she
enthusiastically voiced her support for
hillary clinton and echoed hillary's
insane claim that trump would would
embolden isis no trump actually wiped
them off the planet and sent them
straight to hell where they belong but
don't worry let not your heart be
troubled according to may orcas our new
disinformation minister is totally
neutral with no bias at all who will
only act in the best interest of
americans on a government disinformation
board that will uh never abuse its power
that's what he's saying didn't they tell
us that with fisa warrants yeah i think
they did take a look
will american citizens be monitored no
guarantee that well so what we do we in
the department of homeland security
don't monitor
american citizens you don't but will
this board change that no no the board
does not have any operational authority
or capability what it will do
is gather together best practices in
addressing the threat of disinformation
from foreign state adversaries from the
cartels and disseminate those best
practices to the operators that have
been executing in addressing this threat
for years
also we're supposed to take his word for
it didn't the federal government also
tell us that the fisa program that's
right it would never be used against
americans tell that to carter page and
donald j trump and what about this
shocking report from late last week
detailing how the fbi actually was
caught searching millions of emails and
texts and other electronic
communications of americans without any
warrant whatsoever now the last thing
this country needs is yet another
government program that gets used and
abused to monitor americans
communication i live this life every day
it's a great joy you should try it one
day hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else